But wait, there's more!
The Sharpe ratio for
the same asset can vary widely,
depending on how
frequently you sample it.
So in other words,
if you sample the prices every year, and
compute your Sharpe ratio based on
yearly statistics you'll get one number,
if you sample monthly you'll
get a different number,
if you sample daily you'll
get still another number.
The original vision for the Sharpe
ratio is that it's an annual measure.
So if we're sampling at
frequencies other than annually,
we need to add an adjustment
factor to make it all work out.
So if we have our original
sharp ratio over here
we multiply it by an adjustment factor
called K to get the annualized version.
Now what is K?
K is simply the square root of
the number of samples per year.
Since if we're using daily data.
There are 252 trading days per year,
so K is the square root of 252.
If we're, say, taking weekly samples,
it'd be square root of 52.
Important thing to keep is mind is
the number in here is the rate at which
we're sampling.
So as an example, let's suppose
we were trading for 85 days.
Because we're sampling at a daily rate,
we use this number for our K.
Square root of 252.
Even though we only traded for 89 days,
we use 252 here because
we're sampling daily.
It's the frequency at which we sample
that effects this value for K.
So, recapping, if we sample
the value of our portfolio monthly,
K is the square root of 12,
if we do it weekly,
it's the square root of 52 because
there's 52 weeks in a year, and
if we sampled daily,
it's square root of 252.
Bringing it all together,
if we're using daily data,
our Sharpe ratio is square root of 252,
that's our K,
times mean of our daily returns
minus the daily risk free rate,
divided by standard
deviation of daily returns.